The joe rogan experience.
You're so good at breaking shit down,
dude.
You,
you said that there was
not a hint of bias there.
You were being completely honest about it.
That's,
I really value that in the way you talk.
And uh,
that's why I was really happy when a,
I watched that Kamau bell
show em Kamau Bell Come Matt,
I totally biased for command Melia,
which was a w w Kamau Bell,
you and Lindy West,
Lindy West who's a,
a feminist blogger for Jezza bell,
which is a feminist website.
And what I loved about
it man was first of all,
you never got upset.
You,
you were rational and logical and you had,
you were,
you were talking about it in a very
measured way and you're being really
friendly while you were
discussing this and you know,
in her,
in her defense,
it's a very tricky subject
to breach for a woman.
And she was saying a lot of shit like
comedy clubs are filled with rooms filled
with angry men and he didn't,
he didn't even flinch.
He didn't,
he didn't go after her.
You know,
she had like these digs about like,
you know,
you're allowed to joke about it,
but I'm allowed to tell you're a dick.
You know,
personally,
cause I didn't think she lacked,
she hadn't,
the blog wasn't about me.
It was about a guy who,
any guy making addiction or
certain rape jokes that put,
and this is the tricky part of Lindy West,
he's a lot of people
would say she's against,
she's for censorship,
but she really wasn't.
She was about,
she didn't like the jokes that she thought
minimalize the victim in a rape right
now it's hard to logically say,
well yeah,
minimalize you.
The victim of rape is a good thing.
But she,
you know what,
what people forget,
they went after Sam morale,
a lot of jokes or just misdirection.
He's a comedian in New York who had done
some like domestic violence jokes or
whatever.
But in a misdirection joke,
you,
you go for the,
the,
the most obvious or opposite thing.
So yeah,
sometimes it's like I did one joke
and this didn't come up in that show,
but like I was talking about,
uh,
seeing it a girl,
no,
I don't know if she had a good time
or it was raped in a Porta potty.
I'm not gonna go through
the whole joke before,
but it was at a concert
and outdoor concert.
So the two most opposite things I could
think of if I said I didn't know if she
had a good time or not a very good time,
who gives a shit fuck hill
raped in a Porta potty?
Painting a picture.
If I said I didn't know if she was beaten
in a Porta potty or raped in a Porta
potty,
nobody would've laughed
because they're too close.
So the fact,
I mean,
I'm explaining this to the audience,
not jus the fact that you take two
things at a such polar opposites.
Sometimes the polar opposite you land
on for the joke is a horrible thing that
minimalizes the victim and a,
every Catholic priest joke is
somehow minimalizing the victim part.
Comedy does that.
And I don't believe that it has to
just be speaking truth to power.
I think that's part of it.
But I think that as long as your intention
is genuinely to be funny and not to
humiliate a person for real,
um,
I think it's allowable.
And it has to be because it gets
to be too subjective after that.
Well,
it's an art form.
And if you don't like that art form,
I completely and totally understand that,
right?
You don't have to participate
to participate in the shelves.
You don't have to go.
But when you're,
you're being hypercritical about and
trying to get people to stop doing it,
you're going to make it so that,
that our form is not available.
Like the really fucked up thing that you
don't mean art form is not available.
Just like rap music.
I mean,
what is going on in rap music?
Or they're really running around killing
people and selling cocaine every day.
No.
Most of what they're doing is
talking shit about something.
Right?
It's no different than the movie Scarface.
Nobody really died in that movie.
Okay.
You're,
you're painting a picture.
It's a gross,
horrific picture.
But some people like that,
they like to watch Scarface than
like the listen to rap music.
They want to hear a dirty comic,
say horrendous,
inappropriate things that are fucked up.
One of my favorites is auto,
auto and George.
He would say some of the most fucked up,
ridiculous over the top shit.
But the reason why I did it is because
that's like what shocks is shit out of
you and makes you laugh
when you least expect it.
And it was like,
well crafted in on time.
Top of that.
He made me laugh harder than anybody's
ever made me laugh in a club.
We were doing a pizzeria in
Pennsylvania and he said something.
It was,
it was barbarism.
And it made me,
it was because of the imagery was such,
it was,
it was such poetry that he flew
off the top with and it was awful.
And uh,
have you ever told you this story?
No.
And it was,
it's,
it's like,
it won't hold,
like if I say it now,
it's not gonna be the greatest jokey,
but the beauty of it,
we were in a pizzeria.
It was an awful gig.
And,
um,
it was,
uh,
it was like,
we're like real pizzeria bench seats.
It stunk.
Right.
And,
uh,
there was a bar next to it and I'm
watching it autos just up there,
fucking struggling and hating it.
And in the middle of this dirty act,
the bookers,
Griffin walks down the aisle
with her seven year old son,
which was so inappropriate.
And everybody looked at it,
just derails the show.
And Auto,
uh,
just said,
you know,
cause everyone looked at this.
So the fucking,
the puppet addressed it and said,
uh,
oh,
is it,
I make a,
isn't that cute?
I like to grab him by the ankles and
smashes Skoll onto a fucking sink.
And it was a calligrapher
reference to the end of Caligula.
And it made me the,
the,
the speed at which he put
those words together and the,
the,
the violence attached to that.
Uh,
and the imagery of that.
It May,
I've never laughed wider.
Anything anybody's ever said in a
comedy club because I knew what had just
happened is it was just,
I immediately saw the end
of calendula where they go,
they grab the ankles and they smash
the fucking head into the steps.
And I'm like the genius to
pull that out in this moment.
And where did that quickly,
it's just,
it was,
it was beauty.
It was beauty,
but it was a horror and nobody laughed.
Of course they didn't
fulfill the pizzeria.
He,
nobody understood how funny that was.
He had just said that,
and I hadn't seen calendula.
I might not have laughed as hard,
but the fact that I
immediately saw he did with it,
I was just,
I wanted to hug him for that.
Brilliant,
brilliant guy.
He's a brilliant fuck man.
He's a very funny guy.
And his style of comedy,
much like dice is style,
colony is ridiculous over the top things.
They don't really mean like dice has a
some bit about about how a woman gets
pregnant and it's,
it's,
it's one of the most hilarious,
ridiculous bits because it goes into like
this medical or how you can make a gay
kid,
like how,
you know,
like it's so fucking ridiculous idiocy.
It's completed.
But it's hilarious.
And for people to say that
that's a homophobic joke,
that's like,
no,
he doesn't believe.
He doesn't mean a word.
He's saying,
do you understand that this is,
this is like an art piece
that you're watching.
This is just a ridiculous
over the top art piece.
And for you to say that it's not,
if you to say that I
shouldn't be enjoying it,
well then we have to go with a fine
tooth comb over virtually all of pop
culture,
every song.
We have to find out what the
true meaning behind movies are.
What's the implication on society?
Because he can't just be humor.
It's,
it's,
it's a dumb way of looking
at it because you know,
it's a joke.
If it's a standup comedy show,
you know,
it's a fucking joke.
At least in that sense.
There's no excuse with a rap
music with a rap song like,
no,
it's not a joke.
Maybe he's being serious with a movie.
Maybe they trying to
promote that lifestyle.
Maybe that's real.
It's a standup comedy show.
The only reason why people are
laughing is because it's a joke.
Well,
people do know that,
but it's unfunny people attempting to
influence these people trying to influence
what you said.
It's like the same mentality and I don't
mean individually like let's just say
the same mentality that would
target dice or that would say,
ah,
you should get in trouble for a gay jug.
I the exact same people who would stand
up and defend Maple Thorpe that the same
people who would defend piss Christ and
say that the national endowment of the
arts should have paid for piss Christ
because he'll tell people what that is.
It's it's,
it's,
it's at the NEA and I think paid for,
it was an artist who pissed into a jar
and he put a crucifix in it and he called
it piss Christ.
Now,
I don't think that that's
particularly clever,
but it doesn't offend me on any level.
And here's more and consistency.
It's the same people that clever.
I mean,
it was,
you know,
I look,
I wouldn't have mind.
I wish I would have thought of that.
I mean,
I just,
I couldn't fill a jar
with my pis has been like,
you know,
took weeks.
Yeah.
I really would.
A big jar too.
It's very impressive.
Yeah,
it's a very,
it's a two kegger but,
uh,
the fact that he,
that they support that and at the same
people who would have attacked Giuliani
for going after the fucking Brooklyn
Museum of art because a guy put African
artists painted a,
the Virgin Mary and Dung,
so they would call him a fascist for that.
Um,
you're,
you don't understand art
if you're a maple Thorp,
but you don't understand
art if your TAC piss Christ.
However,
if you attack a comment,
well that conduct is insensitive
and he's saying something racial,
it may actually insensitive or,
or gender attentive and he should be a t.
It's inconsistency.
You can't fucking respect,
respected.
You can't acknowledge
any of it with respect.
It's people have to,
you have to leave room for art.
And that sounds ridiculous when you're
talking Dick Jokes or any kind of jokes,
but you have to leave room for
art because that's what it is,
is just an art.
And if you don't appreciate
that style of art,
it's no different than you deciding to
go to a Metallica show and not liking the
lyrics,
right?
If you don't like it,
you don't have to like it.
There's Jodie Mitchell is
playing down the block.
Go see that.
Go,
go,
go see Sheryl crow or
go see Dave Matthews.
There's a lot of variety out there,
but at the end of the day,
it's something that someone
creates and when I know says,
you know,
I'd like to pick them up by his fucking
ankles and slammed his head into a sink
and you're laughing.
That means he delivered art to
the person who likes that art.
And I feel the same way when I,
when I see,
look,
when I saw dykes or when I saw you,
and Austin,
same feeling.
I enjoy ridiculous over the top humor.
It's my,
one of my favorite things to watch.
So when someone comes along and says,
you can't do jokes about violence
against children cause it's fucked up.
Yes you can.
You can it even if your
kid had been killed.
Well unfortunately for you,
this one hit home and it's not fun to you,
but everybody else doesn't have a kid
that was killed by slamming their head
into a sank.
It becomes fun for them and it sucks,
but you can't just stop the art
form because it's going to hit you.
And that's one of the things that came
up in the conversation with Lindy,
Lindy,
Lindy West,
Lindy West.
Yet one of the things that came up the
conversation with her was that she was
talking about rape jokes and meanwhile
she had a photo on her Twitter of Jeff
Goldbloom who is in Deathwish
with an n w who he had enacted,
had really horrific rape
scene at barbaric rapes in,
you know,
scary,
terrifying,
no joke.
There was no jokes involved.
There was no hee.
He ha ha no double entendres.
And yet an actor doing that in that
piece of art somehow or another is
exonerated from the impact and this idea
that you should know that one third of
the audience I think is those,
the current thing they're enjoying
banding about when people talk about,
I shouldn't say they're enjoying,
I don't want to dismiss it,
but the people who really believe this
believe that one third of all women have
been either sexually assaulted or raped
and there's people that dispute that and
there's a lot of it is based
on a certain study from,
I believe it was 1987 and there was a lot
of questions are very controversial in
that study.
Like they'd say if you ever had sex
with someone then regretted it or we are
recover coerced into having sex
and things along those lines.
They called all of those
rates and so then I think,
but I think their findings was like one
in five but now people are saying it's
one in three whenever the fuck it is.
The idea that you have to like not,
you have to censor
yourself because of the,
you can choose to,
if that's your style of comedy,
but for you to get mad at
someone who doesn't choose to,
it's like,
Ooh,
you're [inaudible].
This is a slippery slope and I know
people don't think it's a slippery slope
because you think it's all just
about protecting people's feelings,
especially victim's feelings.
And I see your point,
but at the end of the day we're going
to have to go over this whole mother
fucker with a fine tooth comb.
If you want to do that,
you can't just single out stand up comedy
because it's coming from one person
and not a giant movie where a woman
gets assaulted and beaten or raped or
whatever.
I mean all of it has to be looked at.
Well,
you have to look at the whole thing.
See I and I also feel like I
give myself the same credit,
like give the audience like I really do.
And it's like we all say,
we want to just just treat people
like you want to be treated well.
I treat the audience with the same level
of intellectual respect that I want.
And I went and saw Joan
Rivers and I am not,
it's the edgiest set I've
ever seen a comic do.
And I mean,
it's a few years ago at the
cutting room in New York,
she's doing nine 11 jokes.
Ai Mean fucking brutal.
And I,
I was,
when I was,
I literally wanted to cry at
the end of it because I'm like,
that is what we should be doing.
It is taking everything
horrible that we experience.
And I mean horrible and making a
roomful of people laugh about it.
And when we walked out of there,
my feelings about nine 11 did not
change my feelings about rape,
my feelings about aids,
not one thing she said made me
value those real experiences.
Less not one thing she said
made me devalue anything,
made me lose respect
for the horror of Nile.
Nothing changed for me other than I was
able to temporarily laugh at something
that I knew was awful.
So why wouldn't I give my audience the
same credit for being able to come to the
conclusion I came to watching Joan Rivers?
Well,
uh,
it to,
to take their argument,
it would be because
you haven't been raped,
you haven't been murdered,
he didn't lose loved ones in nine 11.
And that what you should be doing by
omitting rape jokes is you should be
avoiding triggers.
You get PTSD triggers,
avoiding people freaking out and thinking
about the rape while they're out of
comedy show.
Just try and have a good time.
And so their,
their opinion is set up entirely to
protect the victims of these crimes.
It's not like a person,
like you has a certain sensibility
about nine 11 Joan Rivers defies that
sensibility,
but does it in a humorous way.
And you walk away with the same
opinions that you had going in.
Cause that's not where really
what you're dealing with,
you'd where you're dealing
with is a victimization crime,
a crime or someone's been dehumanized
and them being in the audience watching
you talk about that,
you should be more sensitive than that.
So that's there are there points that
very good argument and a lot of ways my
point back to them would be,
I do understand that.
But like I said,
whenever I talk about tiger woods,
his text messages,
I reveal my own,
I talk about my own.
I also talk about things
that have injured me.
I talk about my own suicide attempts
to my own sexual proclivities like so I
include,
well you do you certain things horrible
and things that have affected me and
things that haven't,
I don't,
it's not like I exclude things.
And if you break down humor like that,
like you said,
fine tooth comb,
every single joke or
90% of the jokes you do,
unless you're talking about
balloons are bouncing a ball,
have hurt somebody.
Well he's talking about De,
oh my God,
was I drunk driving?
Oh my God,
children being killed
by drunk driving is not.
If we get that literal with humor,
then almost all jokes,
comics towel are,
are going to be up for a,
a careful examination.
And I think Matt and Trey said it too.
They're all okay.
We're none of,
it's okay.
I won't make pedophile jokes when Kevin
fucking bacon can't play them in the
woodsmen.
I'll,
I won't do gun jokes when fucking
Hollywood can't tell me how bad guns are.
And then they can move.
He called two guns with too,
which I have no objection to,
but then don't fucking preach
to me about guns motherfuckers.
It's like just,
you know,
I don't care what you do as an artist,
leave me alone as an artist.
I don't tell you what to do.
Don't tell me what to do.
That's all it is.
No,
it's your point is dead on.
And it's a,
it's,
it's a very important point.
The,
uh,
the idea of censorship.
I can understand that people don't want
someone in the audience to be impacted
negatively about you making light of
something that's a horrific crime that
they've suffered from personally.
But that doesn't mean you should stop.
Okay.
And it doesn't mean that
you're a dick either.
What it means is you're saying something
that hits them personally and you know,
then maybe you shouldn't
go see Jim Norton.
And that sounds like a
fucked up thing to say.
But really that's,
that's,
that's the reality of the situation.
This is what you're
doing is a style of art.
People who don't want to be scared don't
go see the conjuring or the evil dead
because they don't like,
I don't like horror movies.
How come nobody's trying
to stop horror movies?
People that don't like them don't go to
see them at the same way she'd be with
certain types of humor.
And what's,
when you break it down,
what's the worst that can happen
if you see something like,
am I going to talk about something
that they don't shell on law and order
constantly?
Jesus,
the whole things up.
Fucking rape murder fest.
And we think people like it is a rape or
a murder or some kind of voyeurism and
I will acknowledge and honor people's Ah,
ah,
porridge to violence.
When does an accident in the southbound
lane and the traffic in my lane doesn't
slow down.
People slow down to look
because they want to see it.
They want to fucking see it on some level,
but they don't admit they want to see it.
And I hate their lack of admission.
Well,
there's a weird exclusion thing too.
If you're,
you're discussing rape and
you're not discussing murder,
you know,
if you even have anything that involves
a rape in a tweet or something,
you're,
you're a piece of shit.
Or,
you know,
you should,
should've had a tour,
a trigger warning in there.
Like,
this is the attitude that a lot of
people are taking it off this stuff.
But why does it have,
why doesn't anybody have the
same issues about murders?
You can talk about a murder.
You can talk.
I'm like,
no,
it's very rare that people get upset
at murder jokes or murder movies or
anything murder.
But there was a Obama thing
recently where Obama said that,
uh,
he could have been
Trayvon Martin and I said,
uh,
you know who else he could have been?
It can be the little kid
that got killed by drones,
right?
No,
nobody.
Right.
That's a a,
I mean,
it's not really a joke per se,
but it's,
it's kind of like blocking him.
You know,
it's,
it's mocking the idiocy of this,
but it's also bringing up murder.
It's bringing up people
getting hit with missiles.
No body's exploding.
Why is that image any less
disturbing than the image of rape?
Are they,
are they equally disturbing
or they both off the menu?
Or why are we only going
with rape off the menu?
How come there's like zero push
to take murder off the menu?
Their argument with BB
King and then again,
this is what they would say is because
rape or murder victims or people murder
is that you're not taught
to be silent about murder.
Okay?
You're taught to be silent about rape
and there's a lot of rape victims who are
too scared to report the crime.
No one is scared to report
a murder lists a mob thing,
right?
They're saying the perception of
the crime is different and our,
there's such a shame with it where
there's not as shame with murder.
This is not a shame
with these other things.
And again,
I heard what she said and I
listened to it and I did get it,
but I won't,
I don't do a whole shitload of
jokes on rape victims anyway.
Um,
but if that's the case and it probably
is the case then be for castration of
rape rapists or,
or fight the fact that the recidivism
rate is so high in these fucking pigs
because they're being let out of jail,
like fight that.
Yeah,
don't worry about what dump contributing
to a fucking rape culture is nonsense.
And it is to say comedian contributes
to rape culture is simply bullshit.
And it's simplistic thinking.
It's a way of saying I don't like what
you're saying and I don't want you to say
it,
but I can't come out with that.
So I have to find a higher reason which
makes it sound like you shouldn't say it
for this reason.
Well,
even the term rape culture,
you know,
someone of my message bird said,
do they have like meetings?
They have a magazine.
Like is it really a culture?
Like what do you,
what are you talking about?
And by calling it that,
by defining it in those terms,
calling it rape culture,
you would,
you put quotes around
that it starts to be real.
And what,
I don't mean that it's going
to encourage people to rape,
but I mean the idea that there is a
culture that supports rape is going to be
real.
It's going to be something that
people dress as if it's real,
regardless of whether or not it is.
Is it real that people rape?
Absolutely,
but it is a real,
that our culture supports it.
Fuck no man.
Of course,
mom,
son,
oh shit.
Itunes or recording to
server the fuck outta here.
Server.